okay
sokolsky
needs uh
to be polished
you you mean he that he was a cheater he
played all right yeah
then don't knock in grace for you if
this was a cheater then
no congrats for you dude
if you were a cheater and shame on you
we kick we keep doing our
our stuffy stuff
like
frankly speaking no idea what's going on
just bringing my guys
to a queen side the king side sorry
queen f3
covering e4
i won't make a pawn okay this is kind of
sikorsky i like
health is a chord's key
which is a risky move i would say five
let's play queen d3 maybe we collect
another pawn on d5
she might play before and uh
make my knight passive though he didn't
do it
okay
a pawn is always
good
so now bishop to d4 knight to c3 okay
i'm just want to trade why not
why not his bishop on c8
his fate is
uh not very brilliant
okay this
you know they say opposite ending
opposite bishop endings are drawish but
i guess this one is uh
not so
this doesn't look a draw to me
doesn't look like a jerky now he's his
pieces are trapped and now his bishop is
going to be lost
check
it takes
thank you very much
okay c4
mine is now d4 then i just take on b4
and then i play d5
and show some mastery in pawn and games
i think i can even take here
very cunning player these guys
but i also go for blockade
[Music]
uh thank you christoph etc